you need to live it how do you break
through by doing so much content for so
long that you start to get an
understanding on the thematics that work
if you think that I woke up one morning
and said you know what we're going to do
in [__] August 2023 on my Instagram
in this highly competitive environment
we're going to make a meme that captures
the essence of the video and we're going
to do a two poost Carousel cuz that's
going to get the most organic reach I
promise you I had no [__] idea if you
think I thought making photos that has a
picture of me in it that then says the
person that's sending you this thinks
and then whatever [__] we've written was
going to be the consistent million
organic reach post when I first posted
the first one I'm like this has no shot
reps